il n'y a pas que les chauffeurs de taxi
qui déposeraient des migrants devant la
frontière canadienne au chemin Roxane
depuis quelques mois selon nos sources
des agents fédéraux américains seraient
eux aussi impliqués dans ce type de
transport certains n'auraient même fait
un commerce et conduirait ces demandeurs
d'asile en dehors de leurs heures de
travail avec leur voiture personnelle
les Américains se moquent du fédéral
leur propre employés de l'État sont des
passeurs à Roxane jamais on aurait
imaginé que lorsqu'on parlait des
passeurs criminels au chemin Roxane on
parlerait des douaniers américains c'est
illégal d'exploiter les demandeurs
d'asile c'est illégal d'aider des
personnes à passer les frontières de
manière irrégulière ce type de transport
pourrait en effet contrevenir aux lois
canadiennes il est interdit à quiconque
d'organiser l'entrée au Canada d’une ou
de plusieurs personnes ou de les inciter
aider ou encourager à y entrer en dehors
d'un point d'entrée officiel ces
révélations interviennent quelques jours
après que la ville de New York débordée
par l'arrivée de milliers de migrants
depuis quelques mois et confirmé
financer des billets d'autobus pour
permettre à ceux qu'ils veulent de se
rendre jusqu'aux chemin roxam je pensais
une vraie enjeu diplomatique pour le
Canada et les Américains
je trouve que c'est pas acceptable on
doit
mettre fin à Roxane et trouver des
façons ordonnées de gérer la frontière
parce que la frontière elle est là et
elle doit fonctionner dans l'ordre et
non pas dans le cadre dans le chaos le
gouvernement logo souhaite désormais une
action rapide de la part d'Ottawa faut
faire en sorte d'atténuer ce mouvement
là et c'est ça pourquoi on demande au
gouvernement canadien de faire en sorte
de régler le problème de Roxane de
fermer l'accès via le chemin Roxane de
fermer l'accès via toute la frontière
canado-américaine en dehors des points
officiels
de continuer notre travail avec nos
partenaires avec les États-Unis pour
morganiser les autoroutes avec les
États-Unis les autorités américaines
suis pas sûr de leur côté prendre très
au sérieux ces allégations et indique
qu'une enquête approfondie et menée ici
romain Suez Radio-Canada Montréal